Wir arbeiten mit denrio-一起 und dem droite Harvard Club.
Monka W.
Auch in Maintenant bin oft gemacht worden...
So...
Auch geht's.
Moin Leute, so...
Was?
Eine Frage...
Will, dass ihr die Gäste in der Gäste-Kamera mit euch beobachtet habt,
dass ihr euch einen Gäste-Kamera-Tourist aus dem Team habt,
den ihr hier in der Gäste-Kamera habt,
den ihr in der Gäste-Kamera habt,
eine Frage...
Will, eventuell, wegen Microsoft Druck, nun doch zu Windows 11 wechseln,
lohnt sich das oder noch bis 2025 warten?
Du meinst 2025, weil dein Windows 10 Support ausläuft, oder was?
Naja, das musst du wissen, was du von Windows 11 haben willst.
Also, ich bin auf Windows 11 umgestiegen,
nicht weil ich so großartigen Bock habe auf Windows 11,
sondern weil meine CPU nur ordentlich von Windows 11 unterstützt wird.
Wenn du nix in der Richtung hast, kannst du dir durchaus noch Zeit lassen.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Es schadet sicherlich auch nix,
ein bisschen vor Support-Ende zu wechseln.
Also, wenn du jetzt easy wechseln könntest,
spricht ja eigentlich auch nix dagegen.
Also ganz ehrlich, 2 Jahre bis zum Support-Ende,
das hat keinen Sinn, da zu jetzt irgendwie bis einen Monat vorher zu warten
und dann quasi umzustellen, festzustellen,
manche Sachen gehen nicht.
Also, schon nicht verkehrt, das jetzt zu machen.
Ja, danke schön.
Massive Subscription.
Magst du alles dringend?
Habe ich gerade schon.
Also, ich denke, das kann man jetzt schon machen.
Ich vermute mal, dass eh schon relativ viele,
also, entweder umgestiegen sind oder sich jetzt auch gerade Gedanken machen.
Ich glaube, insgesamt sind bestimmt noch mehr Leute auf Windows 10 als Windows 11.
War ich mir da nicht sicher, bin ich schon lange keine Statistik gesehen.
Aber das wird die nächsten Jahre über schon zunehmen.
Ich mein, man muss ehrlich mal sagen,
Windows 11 hätte das nicht gebraucht, ja.
Also, was die bei Windows 11 gemacht haben,
hätten die auch alles ohne Probleme machen können.
Oder Windows 10.
Aber man wollte wahrscheinlich mal wieder ein neues Windows verkauft.
Das dürfte der einzige Grund sein.
Ich mein, ich habe es lustigerweise ja schon gesagt,
dass sie 2022 oder irgendwie, wann das 30- oder 50-jährige,
nee, wann gab es das erste Windows, das 30-jährige Windows Jubiläum irgendwie,
aber ich habe selbst ja nicht dran geglaubt, dass das wirklich passiert.
Aber anscheinend hat sich Microsoft gedacht, ja, muss jetzt mal wieder sein.
Und Microsoft redet sich ja auch raus mit, sie hätten nie gesagt,
dass es das letzte Windows ist, was es geben soll.
Und wenn man es mal genau nachguckt, hat das Microsoft auch nie selbst gesagt,
sondern halt, kann man sowieso absichtlich so stehen lassen.
Aber unterm Strich ist es eh egal, was sie sagen.
Die könnten auch offiziell sagen, Windows 11 ist das letzte Windows,
was es hier geben wird.
Und dann einfach drei Jahre später sagen, nee, doch nicht.
Und weiter, also ich meine, was soll passieren?
Da können die Leute sagen, ja, Microsoft, ihr habt aber gesagt,
es ist das letzte, sagt Microsoft, ja, und?
Jetzt halt nicht mehr.
Ich fand diese Windows, nennen wir es mal Windows SS Service Idee,
somit von wegen, wir bringen ein Windows raus und updaten es dann die ganze Zeit,
eigentlich die beste Sache, die sie hätten machen können weiter.
So dieses, ja, wir machen das, aber auch noch ein Upgrade von Windows 10 auf 11,
das fand ich echt bescheuert, weil eines der Vorteile war halt,
dass du nie richtig upgraden musstest.
Er hat zwar unter der Haube oft bald so halbe Neuinstallationen gemacht,
aber auch das haben sie recht gut in Griff gekriegt unter Windows 10.
Und die Leute mögen es einfach, wenn sich nicht so viel auf einmal ändert.
Und vor allem, wisst ihr, was die Leute auch mögen, gerade Windows-User,
wenn der alte Krempel weiterhin funktioniert
und man nicht bei jeder Windows-Version irgendwas downgradet,
aus unerfindlichen Gründen, ja, wie zum Beispiel die Taskleiste in Windows 11.
Ich meine, die Windows 10-Taskbar ist schon deutlich beschissener
als die aus den letzten paar Versionen.
Und Windows 11 ist halt für einen Arsch.
Ja, ob das Geld geht, geht es, glaube ich, gar nicht so sehr.
Ich glaube, das Geld ist den meisten Leuten eigentlich ziemlich wurscht,
was das angeht.
Ich glaube, für die meisten Leute ist eher entscheidender,
wie das halt aussieht mit Arbeit, die man damit hat
und Zeit, mit der man sich auseinandersetzen muss
und Sachen, die sie geändert haben.
Ich glaube, es ist deutlich weniger, wenn das schrittweise geht,
weil dann gewöhnt man sich einfacher dran.
Und die 0-15-User, die mögen es eh nicht, wenn sich was ändert.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe den Eindruck,
dass bei vielen Anwendungen
nur Sachen geändert werden,
um sie tabletartiger zu machen
oder smartphoneartiger zu machen.
Wenn man sich mal Desktop-Anwendungen, Desktop-Anwendungen, wohlgemerkt, ja,
anguckt heute
und, keine Ahnung, 2013 rum,
da sieht man schon einen Riesenunterschied.
Ja, die mögen vielleicht ein bisschen schicker sein.
Diese Oldschool-Windows-Anwendungen waren sicherlich jetzt nicht
die reine Augenweide,
aber oftmals war das relativ gut funktional gemacht
und die hatten auch recht viele Options.
So Thunderbird ist zum Beispiel so ein Ding,
ja, Thunderbird wird oft ein bisschen gehatet,
also das ist nachdem auch so richtig aus der Zeit gefallen
und sonst was in der Richtung.
Aber ich muss halt sagen,
sie haben es auch hier schon versucht, ein bisschen zu ver-tabletisieren, ja.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich mochte das mit den Menüs und dem ganzen Zeug
irgendwie lieber als mit den ganzen Buttons, aber okay.
Aber Thunderbird ist halt noch eine Anwendung,
die erkennst du an, dass es eben eine Desktop-Anwendung ist, ja.
Von den ganzen Schaltflächenmöglichkeiten, was du machen kannst.
Aber viele Anwendungen entwickeln sich halt
auf dem Desktop Richtung Tablet
und das finde ich schon seit Jahren ziemlich beknackt.
Hast du eigentlich AWS-Zertifizierung?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Warum mit AWS?
Also AWS ist mit Abstand die Cloud,
wo ich am wenigsten besser gemacht habe mit.
Obwohl, glaube ich, AWS mit die ersten waren in vielen Bereichen,
kann das sein?
Ich bilde mir das ein, dass das ungefähr so in der Reihenfolge war.
AWS bzw. Amazon hat diesen ganzen Cloud halt mit losgetreten.
Auch oftmals, das war auch noch zu Zeiten,
da war Kubernetes und sowas noch gar nicht richtig etabliert.
Und danach kam Google und ich glaube,
mehr oder weniger zeitgleich, wenn nicht ein bisschen später, Azure.
Also ich glaube, es war die Reihenfolge AWS, Google, Azure.
Natürlich nicht insgesamt,
aber bei verschiedenen Technologien waren die ein bisschen schneller als die anderen.
Was Kubernetes-Sachen angeht, war Google lange Zeit ganz gut dabei
und sind sie immer noch.
Naja, gut.
Letztendlich ist auch wurscht, wer da zuerst da gewesen ist.
Zumindest habe ich mit AWS noch am wenigsten gemacht bisher.
Ja, das ist halt kacke.
Dass die Dinge responsive sind, das soll mir ja recht sein,
gerade bei Web-Anwendungen ist ja okay,
aber bei Anwendungen, die explizit halt für den Desktop gemacht werden.
Vergleicht mal zum Beispiel, falls dieses Ding noch einer kennt,
diesen Musik-Player hier,
das ist der Musik-Player,
der Musik-Player,
diesen Musik-Player hier
mit, ähm,
das ist halt so eine typische Windows-Anwendung von der Optik her aus,
keine Ahnung, 2000 bis 2015 so rum vielleicht
und vergleicht das mal mit aktuellen Musik-Playern.
Ja, genau.
Aktuelle Musik-Player sehen dann eher so aus
und hier kannst du halt noch was machen.
Das fuckt mich jedes Mal richtig ab,
wenn ich in irgendwelchen Musik-Streaming-Diensten bin
und du hast so unsinnliche Beschränkungen,
wie du kannst die Lautstärke nur in festgelegten Schritten verändern
oder sowas, ja.
Oder das Playlist-Handling ist halt Smartphone und nicht Maus-kompatibel
und solche Dinger, das nervt mich dann immer,
wenn ich mir denke, alter, das ging doch früher auch wunderbar zu bedienen,
warum muss man das so beschissen machen mittlerweile auf dem Desktop?
Ja, Winamp war eh so eine Sache für sich.
Winamp gibt es ja mittlerweile sogar.
Es ist ja sogar mittlerweile...
...gibt es ja sogar mittlerweile im Browser.
Und um nicht zu vergessen, das Standard-Winamp-Ding, was immer drin war...
...das war der Standard-Sound, der immer, wenn du Winamp installiert hast
und gestartet hast, Standard-mäßig dabei war.
Das war der Standard-Sound, der immer, wenn du Winamp installiert hast
und gestartet hast, standardmäßig dabei war.
淡水小混合
iTunes...
...ne, iTunes mag ich nicht.
Aber Winamp war schon extrem porc.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich Winamp auch heute noch verwenden.
Gibt's Leute von euch, die Winamp verwenden immernoch?
2023.
Gibt es das...
Gibt es das eigentlich überhaupt noch?
...
Öh!
Alter, das ist ja die schlimmste...
...
Okay, das dürfte glaube ich das negativ Beispiel schlechthin sein für Vertablitisierung eine Anwendung schlechthin, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Das sieht aus wie jeder 0815...
...
...nur nach 15 Streaming Audio plus als Desktop Player.
Ah, fucker.
...
…
..
...
....